[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
soy herminia Fernández por Andrés
espinal tras ocho meses de guerra los
prisioneros se han acumulado a ambos
lados de la frontera sin embargo un
centro de detención el oeste de Ucrania
se está llenando de detenidos rusos
algunos de los cuales están gravemente
heridos quien intenta demostrar que está
respetando los Derechos Humanos a los
prisioneros esto es un informe de
vericaval y francesto
este edificio en el oeste de Ucrania se
ha transformado en un centro de
detención para prisioneros de guerra
rusos estos hombres fueron apresados por
las tropas ucranianas en plena batalla y
algunos tienen graves heridas de guerra
en febrero mi convoy sufrió una
emboscada allí perdí la pierna
se supone que actualmente hay varios
cientos en la prisión pero se desconocen
las cifras oficiales los detenidos
tienen derecho a dos horas de televisión
al día con noticias ucranianas
no entiendo nada las autoridades rusas
nos decían una cosa y acá escucho lo
contrario intento compararlo pero no hay
nada Claro los funcionarios ucranianos
se mantienen firmes en que de acuerdo
con la convención de Ginebra los
detenidos son tratados con dignidad y
respeto a los derechos humanos y cuando
se preguntó a los prisioneros por sus
condiciones Si la presencia de la
seguridad reafirmaron que son bien
tratados e incluso se les permite Llamar
a sus familias en ocasiones todos ellos
hablaron de irse con suerte mediante un
intercambio de prisioneros entre los dos
países
le dije a mi madre que estoy bien y sano
pero que espero desesperadamente que me
intercambien no quiero que se preocupe
demasiado
estos dos hombres en la enfermería
tienen 20 y 21 años el primero perdió
las dos piernas por una mina terrestre
en el frente y dice que fue operado y
atendido por los ucranianos
No tengo ánimo Pero tengo que aguantar
cada día tengo que volver a aprender
cosas
espero conseguir una prótesis y que la
vida pueda empezar de nuevo
la cruz roja ha visitado la prisión pero
aún no ha publicado sus conclusiones
Aunque hay otros centros de detención
para prisioneros rusos en toda Ucrania
donde se desconocen sus condiciones
las exportaciones de alimentos en
Ucrania uno de los principales
exportadores de cereales del mundo
vuelven a estar en peligro Rusia
suspendió su participación en el acuerdo
de cereales el mar Negro alegando un
supuesto ataque por parte de kiev a
Marcos rusos en el puerto de sebastopol
El pacto ha firmado el 22 de Julio había
permitido Ucrania exportar millones de
toneladas de cereales si el acuerdo no
se reactiva los agricultores ucranianos
dicen que no podrán financiar la próxima
temporada de siembra ni obtener
beneficios más detalles en el siguiente
informe de Gulliver crack
en un año normal Este campo de maíz ya
habría sido cosechado
ya está seco tenemos que traerlo 5000
toneladas de maíz hay que transportarlas
a algún sitio inmediatamente a los que
necesitan No necesitamos tanto
pero por ahora esta agricultor y
voluntario de la defensa territorial no
tiene más remedio que dejar el maíz en
el campo o de esa lleva ya dos semanas
paralizada Desde hace dos semanas no hay
prácticamente ninguna posibilidad de
vender grano a través de los puertos de
la región de Odessa
aparte de los puertos del mar Negro No
hay forma realista de exportar las
cantidades necesarias
el corredor de cereales era un
salvavidas absoluto para nosotros sin él
no habríamos podido vender nuestros
productos así conseguimos vender la
mitad de nuestro trigo y la mitad de
nuestra cebada a través de ese corredor
de cereales
lo que queda está en estos graneros
que podemos hacer solo almacenar
el viernes en uno de los puertos de la
región de Odessa el icaria Angel estaba
haciendo cargado con 30.000 toneladas de
trigo con destino a Etiopía
Ucrania rechaza las acusaciones rusas de
que el acuerdo no ha ayudado al
continente africano tuvo africans que
creen se han enviado 51 buques a países
africanos con 1,2 millones de toneladas
de carga teniendo en cuenta que en total
han navegado unos 400 barcos gracias a
este corredor eso significa que más del
10% fue a África
sin embargo ahora no está nada Claro si
este barco usar para el domingo como
estaba previsto
los combates continúan en la región de
gerson desde hace semanas el ejército
ucraniano está desarrollando su
contraofensiva para recuperar la
principal ciudad de las fuerzas rusas
pero con un alto coste humano las tropas
de kiev intentan actualmente rodear este
territorio estrechamente situado en la
orilla occidental del río nieper
nuestros corresponsales de Francia 24
acompañaron a una unidad de artillería
ucraniana en la línea del frente entre
nikolai y gerson aquí el informe de
Jonathan walsh y Jean Emily
para estos artilleros ucranianos no hay
un segundo que perder los servicios de
inteligencia militar acaban de localizar
varios objetivos con la ayuda de aviones
no tripulados que planean sobre ellos
[Música]
los tanques y las trincheras rusas están
ahora en su línea de visión extendidos a
lo largo de las afueras del Oeste De
gerson
vladislab comanda esta unidad está a
cargo de ajustar cada disparo y recibe
información continua antes de cada
decisión
estamos constantemente haciendo
correcciones el último disparo cayó a
cinco o diez metros del objetivo para la
artillería es un buen trabajo infligimos
daños a su Infantería se pusieron a
cubierto pero conseguimos darles la
unidad participa en la contraofensiva
hacia gerson que deja desplegado miles
de soldados aquí con el objetivo de
rodear la capital de la región que fue
tomada por los rusos al comienzo de la
guerra
Pero a medida que se acercan a la ciudad
El Avance se hace más difícil por ahora
los artilleros vuelven a su base a unas
decenas de kilómetros al oeste de gerson
dicen estar de buen humor
nota nuestra Infantería está ganando
terreno metro a metro Aunque el terreno
sea difícil estamos haciendo todo lo
posible para ayudarles No creo que nos
detengamos solo en gerson volveremos a
las fronteras de 1991 retomando crimea
porque crimea es parte del territorio
ucraniano
las tropas ucranianas se han mantenido
optimistas en esta carrera contra el
tiempo ahora Solo queda un simple
objetivo por delante recuperar jerson
antes del Invierno
una grave crisis económica está
golpeando a Italia la tercera economía
de la zona Euro desde el inicio de la
guerra en Ucrania el país sufre una
fuerte presión inflacionaria con
aumentos exponenciales en los precios de
la energía y el gas la situación sacude
particularmente al sector de los lácteos
y del queso parmigiano relleno producto
símbolo del país que se ha exportado al
mundo entero nuestros corresponsales en
Italia Natalia Mendoza y Simone bauduco
nos cuentan más
desde hace tres generaciones la familia
de Cristina marassicría ganado y produce
leche para el emblemático queso
parmesano en esta granja de la periferia
de parma aquí Los costos de producción
se han disparado en los últimos meses
los precios de los servicios son los
aumentado mucho pero también el alimento
para las vacas y las materias primas del
establo han subido espantosamente
para reducir estos costos Cristina ha
decidido como otros ganaderos de la zona
disminuir su número de reses consciente
de que esto reducirá En parte los 17.000
quintales de leche que producía
anualmente hasta ahora
tuvimos que vender algunos animales a
duras penas logramos cubrir el precio
del mantenimiento Y no tiene ningún
sentido tener los animales en el establo
la consecuencia es el aumento del precio
de la leche una mala noticia para Pablo
llenary uno de los 300 productores de
queso certificado parmigiano rellano de
controlado en su fábrica el costo de la
energía triplicó en el último año
tenemos costos de energía importantes
porque usamos máquinas que producen
vapor para cocinar el queso y eso se
hace gracias a unas calderas especiales
el queso producido hoy deberá madurar
durante unos dos años antes de ser
vendido una incertidumbre que preocupa a
Los profesionales del sector esta tarde
en las oficinas del principal sindicato
agrícola del país varios productores han
venido buscando soporte
el riesgo para nosotros es que hoy
sabemos cuánto nos cuesta producir el
queso pero no sabemos Cuál será el
precio de ese queso en 2 años
nuestras empresas están en crisis de
liquidez y no resistirán mucho tiempo
sosteniéndosemejantes costos productivos
rellano producen unos 2 millones y medio
de euros anuales un sector que amenaza
de desplomarse si los precios de la
energía siguen aumentando en Italia
una Nueva Ola de calor se extiende por
Francia la ciudad es el suroeste del
país llevan una semana con temperaturas
superiores a los 25 grados Celsius e
incluso con picos de 30 grados
Estableciendo
récords para esta época del año esto es
un informe de France
otoñal solo sol y arena ya que los
veraneantes del suroeste de Francia
están tomando el sol en lo que se supone
es su descanso de finales de octubre en
algunas zonas hace más calor que a
finales de junio es increíble
en el resto del departamento de las
landas los cafés y las Terrazas están a
tope de momento lo aprovecharemos Pero
sería bueno volver a las temperaturas
normales
las temperaturas de octubre han subido
drásticamente a causa de un gran sistema
de bajas presiones en el Océano
Atlántico que está trayendo aire cálido
desde España y el norte de África y deja
a las ciudades entre 8 y 9 grados más
calientes de lo habitual un tiempo tan
caluroso Es raro en esta época del año
donde las temperaturas normales de
octubre suelen estar por debajo de los
17 grados esta semana están alcanzando
un máximo de 30 es un poco extraño
vestirse como si estuviéramos al final
del verano cuando en realidad estamos al
final de octubre según los meteorólogos
esta ola de calor tardía Aunque única
puede repetirse en el futuro ya hemos
tenido bolas de calor en el pasado que
han durado de 3 a 4 días pero ahora
mismo estamos en el undécimo día y a
finales de mes habremos tenido una ola
de calor de 17 a 18 días la hora de que
azota a la Francia continental durará
hasta el final de la semana Gracias por
acompañarnos en corresponsales en
nuestro agradecimiento esa casa 7322 por
habernos permitido Grabar en sus
instalaciones el día de hoy siga con más
información en Francia 24 y France
24.com